so remember I went to Brandeis at a time
where the internet was just starting so
we didn't have social media and we
didn't have cell phones
so slightly different context as well
about how the value of emotional
intelligence how it works right because
I think it's more complicated now
for sure and I think that the Youth of
today have more disadvantages in in you
know
like when you're feeling a little bit
lonely you can Retreat to social media
you know and you can avoid having to
have difficult conversations you can
turn on your Tech talk and cry to your
cell phone in your room by yourself and
you can get lots of likes and external
affirmation but that that's not
vulnerability go have that exact same
conversation and cry to the the friend
that hurt you that's way more difficult
and I think we avoid those conversations
because it's just easier and I think
unbalanced not exclusively but imbalance
we see a younger generation that's very
afraid of being uncomfortable they like
to avoid discomfort unbalance and so one
of the things that I learned at Brandeis
was being uncomfortable
you know
I've got a roommate
for the first time I had a roommate who
I signed up to live with a non-smoker
okay my roommate signed up to be with a
non-smoker turns out my roommate was a
smoker who didn't want to live with a
smoker
you're an right so now I gotta
live with a smoker
right I had to learn to live with that
I had to learn to live with a roommate
that used to screw with my stuff because
he thought it was cool with his friends
and so like he would just I he'd like
just screw with my stuff and so I
learned to not believe in Revenge
right I learned not to believe in
Revenge and the reason is simple is
because when we did have a fight I could
say you did this and this and this and
this and he couldn't say anything
because I don't believe in Revenge I
didn't do anything back
right I learned that skill because of my
my my useless roommate my freshman year
at Brandeis I had to learn it it was a
survival mechanism otherwise I'm going
to be screaming yelling all the time
right and I'm gonna two rights don't
make a wrong I had to learn that too
right but one of the best lessons I
learned at Brandis and one of the great
things about Brandeis as a relatively
small school
you have relatively small class sizes
and more importantly you have a very
very small student to teacher ratios you
know our classes are taught by
professors you go to Harvard they're
going to be taught by Tas because all of
the good professors go work with The
Graduate students right so you get
access to brilliant brilliant people in
small class sizes this is amazing this
is a gift and one of the things that I
learned was that I have I am allowed to
disagree with someone who has more
degrees and more letters at the end of
their name than I do as long as I can
make a constructive and respectful
argument screaming and yelling is not
the way I disagree telling somebody that
they're wrong is not the way I disagree
but mounting an argument in a respectful
way is something I learned at Brandeis
so I would have the emotion to disagree
but I had to learn how to disagree in a
constructive way
very grateful to Brandeis for giving me
that and that I could do it in these
small class sizes where I could talk
directly to the authority
um so super grateful for a lot of the
human skills that I learned at Brandeis
and I think one of the great things that
we learn in college whether you know you
know there's a lot of debate whether
college is useless or not in this modern
day and age and yes I mean the studying
part may or may not be useful
um but the it's a halfway house to the
real world you know
um and I think that you're learning to
transition to adulthood you're learning
to transition to Independence
um and most importantly
um you learn to think critically
um you know where College is very
different than High School and the way
professors talk to you and the way you
can talk to your professors is very
different than High School
and critical thinking is the thing you
need to do and you're talking to
professors who don't necessarily know
the answers themselves in high school
they know all the answers
right and so you're about it's about
problem solving and that's really hard
when sometimes there is no right answer
um that's even harder you're doing work
in in your category where sometimes
there actually is no answer
and so what you're teaching is how to
think
not what the answer is and that skill
how to think rather than know the answer
for the test is more valuable in my life
than pretty much anything I've ever
learned